[Music]
good evening everyone my name is Mahesh
Narayan I'm a product manager in Google
cloud I'm joined by two other product
managers Olivia Warren Warren Warren
okay what train who is also a product
manager in Google Cloud and aleem Karim
who's abroad majorie NetApp and they're
also going to make sure that nobody's
sleeping so please keep your eyes open
they can I can't all right hopefully
that got some laughs all right so just
some housekeeping we have the Dory Q&A
so if you have any questions please
about the session please submit them
through the nori tool it's an internal
tool in Google that we use quite a lot
gives an opportunity for everybody to
ask questions
the catch is if you like a question
please upload them so that there's a
higher probability of those questions to
be asked okay so a very simple and easy
way to connect to any Google service is
through internet so if you are on Prem
you can get a dedicated internet access
and connect to Google service if you are
consuming these services from VPC or
from GCP whether it be a GC instance or
a GK cluster we have by default public
IPs and you can connect to them easily
but there is a lot of companies have
security and compliance requirement
which mandates that you do not use
public ip's right so to meet that
mandate you have a cloud VPN or you buy
an interconnect service from Google such
as a dedicated internet or partner
interconnect on the GCP side you deploy
VMs without a private IP or you create
private GK clusters so the problem
statement now becomes how do you connect
to Google services privately from on
Prem as well as from GCP
so the agenda of this session is to talk
about whether different types what are
the different types of managed services
on Google and then provide you the
solutions that are available to connect
privately to these services and to round
it out we will have Ali talked about how
they are using one of these solutions to
offer cloud volume product from NetApp
on GCP so there are primarily two types
of Google services
the first service is is hosted on Google
infrastructure and it is front ended by
an internal Google proxy from the
computer resources such as a GCE or a GK
he cluster examples of such services are
GCE Google Cloud Storage bigquery cloud
spanner and the solution that is
available to connect to these services
privately is called private Google
access the second type of Google service
is is the one that is hosted on the
Google cloud infrastructure and we use
VPC peering as a primitive to connect to
these services so think of these
services as another customer on Google
cloud but this happens to be a service
that Google provides it's hosted by
Google example or self service such
services are cloud sequel if you are
using GK then GK private clusters and
the solution to connect to these
services privately is called private
service access so these are the two
services so we looked at just to recap
we have two different types services one
hosted on Google infrastructure the
other hosted on Google cloud
infrastructure and the ones hosted on
Google cloud infrastructure is called
private service access the one that is
hosted on Google infrastructure the
solution is called private Google access
I will talk about private Google access
Olivia and aleem are going to talk about
private service access but before we go
into the solutions let's take a step
back
and get a good understanding of what a
VPC is in GCP because that forms the
basic building block of all these
services oops
so in in a V PC is basically a
customer's a customer's network in
Google Cloud it's a virtual network and
it is global in nature what global means
is let's say you have a deployment in
u.s. West and another deployment in u.s.
East we do not require you to create two
different V pcs if you have a deployment
in East US East and u.s. West you do not
need two different V pcs if they want to
talk to each other with global VP sees
these two deployments can talk to each
other automatically without any special
provisioning on your side we also offer
V PC peering so if you have a V PC in
your project in your AAG you can connect
to another V PC in the same project or a
different project in your arm or you can
connect to another V PC in a totally
different org so that's what we PCP are
in provides now let's talk about private
Google axis we saw how internet was not
an option to connect to these services
so previously it was a simpler task to
figure out where the service whether
requests to these services coming from
because each customer gets a unique
public IP with private IP we need to
understand which customer is sending
this this request this black box to the
customer is is a proxy is an internal
Google proxy which we call Google Cloud
front-end so it's called a cloud
front-end proxy what it does is like a
gateway it connects the customers
network to the Google infrastructure the
service is lying on Google
infrastructure it understands what IPS
does a customer's VPC have and make sure
that the traffic is routed back to it
now that we understand the glue let's
look let's see what are the the what is
the workflow in setting up private
Google access so the first step is to
advertise a specific a new prefix and
make
DNS changes and this is pretty much
these are the two steps whether you are
on on Prem
or if you are on cloud if you are using
from a GC or a GK cluster let's look at
the set up for for on Prem so I talked
about you know announcing a special
prefix a new prefix why do we need that
well
Google API is Google services already
have a have a public IP you know you are
routing to them publicly or Internet so
we need a special or a new prefix that
identifies identifies the private path
to these services and this is called a
restricted VIP if you were to do an
nslookup on the restricted web you will
get a slash 30 block which is 199 36 150
3.4 slash 30 even though it's a although
it's a public IP it is not publicly
routable okay so now that we have this
restricted web you can go on your cloud
router which is you know something that
you'll be using if you are doing cloud
VPN or an interconnect partner or
dedicated create a custom route with
this slash 30 block and an on-set over b
bgp to on trim now your on-prem
resources have this route but how does
the application how does the client
libraries know that they need to send
traffic to this best last 30 we
obviously don't want you to change your
applications so the simplest way to
achieve this is through dns right and
there are three popular ways of doing
this from on-prem you can change the
config map to resolve start or google
api is calm to restrict at Google APs
com if you are on GCP you can use the
cloud DNS product and specifically
private the private zone feature within
cloud DNS to you know resolve the star
dot Google an API to a cname to
restricted Google API is calm and also
you can use you know on GCP bind or any
other DNS of your choice now if you're
setting up connectivity private
connectivity from
VPC resources computer resources on VPC
such as a GC or a GK cluster you need to
select the a subnet there is a flag
called private Google access so you need
to select that and then once you create
the VM you ensure that the VM is created
on this particular subnet please keep in
mind that the V PC has has a routing
table and the default route of that
routing table still says Internet
gateway so when you send out with this
setup when you send out a request to a
Google API comm and start out Google API
comm it uses the default route but even
though it says the Internet gateway it's
not actually actually it's the traffic
still stays on Google backbone the the
other step is the so there is also like
I just talked about how there is a
routing table and the default route
points to Internet gateway to from a
security perspective if you want to lock
down your network and if you want to
remove this default route you can go
ahead and do that and you can have the
same 199 36 150 3.4 slash 30 restricted
whip you can create a static route with
that pointing to the default internet
gateway I'll reiterate even though it
says default internet gateway the
traffic is not going out to Internet it
stays within Google backbone and any
traffic in Google that is destined
towards this slash 30 restricted web OSD
layer is smart enough to realize that
this traffic is destined to a service
behind the Google proxy right so these
are some of the steps that you can take
to to connect to services privately
using private Google access with that
I'll hand out headed over to Olivia
you okay yes perfect
so thanks Mahesh so we just looked at
how do we connect services that are on
the Google infrastructure so services
such as just yes spanner and so on so we
are now looking not going to look at the
services that are hosted inside the
Google cloud infrastructure inside GCP
and some column attic so we are going to
the poem statement is how can I access
from my V PC from a service in V PC to
this marriage service privately with a
via private IP and also how can I do
that from on time so from on prime to my
managed service without going through
internet so services on the disappea in
future infrastructure our services like
cloud SQL cloud filer GK private master
and so on so who is using cloud SQL here
who has already used cloud the square
here okay who has used cloud SQL with a
private IP already okay so I see a lot
of hand for cloud SQL but not cloud a
square with a private IP so cloud the
square with private IP is a service that
has been launched I think it was back in
September and it's using the
functionality time that I'm going to
describe right now okay so service is in
top of GCP are using the same building
block that any other service on GCP that
me that we are using vp c vm and so on
so you have on the left side you have a
consumer of EPC so a consumer that we
like to use the service and on the right
side we have the producer of EPC - the
producer that has developed a service
that is managing the service how do we
connect to the PC together on GCP we are
using VPS appearing and that's a way we
connect privately from a consumer to a
private to a producer
that Vantage of apiece appearing is
because there's no poxy and no device
between the two VPC it's direct
connection between the two VPC it's high
school boots and very low delay which is
very important for database type of
services at the same time the policy of
EPC is going to be unique for each
consumer VPC so every time a consumer
will have to create a new service we are
going to have a specific policy of EPC
for the service to have a security
between all those instances so before
explaining how to use whip-it appearing
for the unplanned connectivity and so on
I need to take a quick segue and explain
a new feature that we launched for next
and this feature is the capacity to
exchange our custom routes with VPC
peering and you're going to see later
how we are using this feature for
unplanned creativity in a V PC we have
three types of routes we have subnet
routes we have static routes and we have
dynamic or BGP routes that subnet route
our route that are already automatic
created by the system static and BGP
routes route that are created by the
user of the BBC right and that's why we
call static and dynamic routes custom
routes because you can customize them by
default with VPC peering only subnet
router exchange so by default when you
do with peace appearing all the subnets
exchanged but the static and busy period
are not exchanged so to allow the
exchange of static and dynamic routes we
have flags that you can update on the V
PC peering so we have import and export
flag on each side of the V PC peering
connection that means four flags right
202 on the first PC and 200 on the so
VPC an import and export flag on each
side if you have an export flag for
custom route as true that means that you
are ok to send those route to your next
VP see if you set the flag and import as
true
let me that you are ok to learn the
routes from the other VPC for those of
you that are familiar with BGP that
seems that should be very familiar to
you it's very similar to policy-based
routing on typical routers let's take an
example so in this example I have two V
PC and my goal here let's assume that my
goal is to quit a route for a specific
subnets I would like to send traffic to
the VMB that is on the right side
alright so I have my VM a for specific
destination I would like to have as a
next stop VM be on the right side well
GCB today it is not possible to critter
static routes with a next stop on
another V PC so how do we do that
without creating a static route with an
export with a next stop in another V PC
so the first way the first thing is we
need to create a static route on the
sole on the PC okay so let's look at the
routing table for one minute so on each
EPC here we have a subnet that's why we
have a local route that the subnet
routes and we have the route to the
subnet on the other V PC right with next
stop P so 10.30 is my local subnet 10
what 40 is my subnet on V PCB now that I
configured static routes on the V PCB I
see your serve routes on the right side
I see a third route which is my static
routes with 10 dot 100 sending traffic
as an extra B&B but still
it's not enough because on VPC a I can
still not see the rounds so the next
step is to configure an export policy on
the PCB so that I can say please export
that route to VP CA but you can see it's
not enough because even with the export
I don't see the routes on the routing
table of V PC a so what is missing is an
import statement so an import flag as
true if I put the import flag as true
then suddenly I see the static routes on
my routing table ok so you can see that
I need to configure both flag for
security reason so Basra PCT to agree on
what to exchange and what's that done
I'm exchanging my static route or my BGP
route between maybe PC another another
use case for the exchange of static and
dynamic routes is what we call transit V
PC so with 23 PC let's say that I would
like to share a VPN or an interconnect
or cross multiple V PC I mean obviously
a simple way to do that would be to have
multiple VPN with a very complex or
expensive so let's say that I would like
to share a VPN or interconnect across
multiple V PC so way to do that is to
have to quit to create a V PC but we
would call a 23 PC this V PC can be
empty or with all sources in it and in
this VPC I'm going to have export flag
on all the other V PC and automatic
automatically all my routes are going to
be exchanged between
on-prem to all the V PC here so it's
dynamic so even if you change routes on
on-prem automatically with BGP and with
my export policy all the V PC will be
updated with the new routes some
advantage of this solution so there's no
bandwidth limit is V PC peering
so with VPC peering there's no bandwidth
limit
it's direct connection VPC peering is
free beside the price of egress of
normal traffic usage so busy peering is
free and every time every type of
connectivity is reported
so it's VPN but it's also interconnects
okay now that we looked at this new
feature how to exchange route between
all the type of road between my VPC how
can I use that for my prom statements
and my problem statements is again how
can i connect from my own prom to my
managed services and for to connect from
on-prem to my managed service privately
I need to add two things I need to
exchange routes between on Prime and V
PC and Mac and my VP's in the consumer V
PC and I need to exchange all those
routes between the consumer V PC and the
managed service okay so let's do that
one by one first I have V PC peering
between the managed service and the
consumer of this service I'm exporting
all the routes to the match Service BBC
and then I need to configure a custom
advertisements on the cloud router of
the consumer V PC to send those rounds
to on time
so with those two step export of routes
to the major v3 PC and the BGP
advertisements to 1:00 p.m. a full
continuity and to end between the own
Prime and my manager is okay but that
could be a bit complex right I mean so
let's say let's assume that I just want
to to have a cloud SQL instance or let's
say I want to have a simple MySQL
database now suddenly I need to
understand VPC peering and it wanders
and export/import
might be a bit complex so how can we
simplify all this and the way we
simplified all this is by creating a new
a new scheme called private service
access now in GA and the way to think
what private service access is it's a
it's a managed VPC peering connection so
when I want to create a simple service
like MySQL instance the BPC peering
connection will be automatically created
for me right all the step will be done
for me so I don't need to understand the
disappearing for a simple service for a
simple service creation so how'd that
work in details let's assume that I am
the owner of a V PC so here it's a V PC
green so let's assume that I'm the owner
of the V PC green and I would like to
create a MySQL instance my first step is
to decide which IP range my service
should use so it's to allocate a range
for all my managed services this range
can be slash 24 can be as small as an
slash 24 all can be larger because it
can be larger because it will be shared
across all my services so let's say I
would like to have 5100 services I can
have a large range and each one of them
can pick a different IP in this range so
we do advise to use a large range if
possible that many customers cannot have
large range because they don't have a
lot of private IP available but if you
can it's better to have a large range
like a slash 16 and then every time you
quit a new service they can pick
addresses form from this range so in
this example
I'm the owner of VPC green I located a
slash 24 on the right side you can see
the UI of the cloudy squirrel creation
and it's as simple as clicking on
private IP instead of public IP so if
you go to advanced option on MySQL on
cloud SQL MySQL there's an option on
advanced networking to select private IP
so when you select private IP connect
automatically the system is going to
pick to create a MySQL instance in a V
PC using the right IP range using a
private IP in the ranges you selected
and we automatically creates the VP's
appearing for you
now that we I gave an example for one
service let's take an example with two
service or multiple services in this
example again and the owner of the green
V PC and I would like to services
instead of one same way I can go on the
UI and say I would like to have a
service from the tap or from Google and
the system is going to create
automatically one V PC peering per
producer of those services so in this
case if that says as to producer Google
and a tap I'm going to have a V PC
peering for each one of them
share the pieces report so the issue
with selfie PC is in this case there's
two service projects in in my VP in my
share the business so we share EPC I can
divide my VPC in multiple service
projects so that each team can have
different billing and different iron
rights for the office oxygen may be busy
the issue with cheri PC in this case is
typically the owner of a service project
do not have permission to create the
VP's appearing and so entirely they
cannot the owner of size project cannot
create connection to a service because
it will have its permission and they
need to ask you for every creation of
service they need to ask the permission
from the network admin from the network
and the owner of the shell jeppesen so
the way we solve that is yes for the
first connection to a service provider
you do need to ask for permission but
for every other connection the VP's
appearing is already there and so you
don't need to ask for permission
so the permission is asked once once for
every service provider and when the
service provider when the connection has
been created to the service provider
each owner of those services of this
overall service project can creat the
instances without asking for permission
to summarize to summarize Mahesh
discussed about all the services running
on the Google infrastructure I discussed
about the services running on the Google
infrastructure on the GCP and Google
cloud infrastructure and there's two
solution
one for each the services on the Google
infrastructure like just yes like
spanner use something called private
Google access the services built on GCP
like cloud SQL readies memcache or TPU
or GK private master are using private
service access and private service
access is using PPC peering private
Google access is using a proxy to
separate the GCP infrastructure and the
Google infrastructure so we are now
going to to see how NetApp has built
their services using private service
access and how the new sleep is
appearing to give a very low latency
file or application can you guys hear me
okay
[Music]
thanks Olivia so just a quick show of
hands who has heard of cloud volumes in
the solution that NetApp and Google are
building together marketing departments
doing something so that's good
so just for a recap what is cloud
volumes what does it do who's interested
in it I'll just spend one slide covering
that essentially cloud volumes is a
fully managed cloud native file services
offering it's really meant to provide
high throughput low latency NFS and SMB
storage and it's really targeted at
moving enterprise applications that
customers used to run on premise into
GCP so really used for things like s AP
or running other enterprise applications
like content management systems b2b
e-commerce systems and such typically
what you'll find is you know there's
also a set of industries like media and
entertainment like life sciences as well
as genomic sequencing that are
interested in running
Nazz specific applications in GCP and
these are basically industries that have
been using Nazz on-premise for a very
very long time and therefore have tools
processes and skill sets built around
nas and they want to extend these into
public cloud gzp more specifically and
therefore they need management solutions
in GCP to move these business processes
or applications over in terms of who's
interested in a solution like cloud
volumes typically it is cloud architects
or application owners who have been
tasked with essentially either moving a
business process or an application into
GCP and ultimately its application teams
being able to then provision and manage
these NFS or SMB endpoints themselves
once they're in GCP so on the right hand
side is a quick screenshot of what this
looks like
basically it's a it's a native interface
into GCP through the cloud console our
customers can go in create a volume and
essentially consume it for it from
either GCE or gke instances so one quick
slide here to show what the architecture
of cloud volumes looks like there's a
dotted line in the in sort of the middle
of the
that sort of separates the control plane
from the data plane I'll talk about the
control plane quickly as I said the
users enter into a cloud volume service
through their normal pathways either
through the cloud console or using the
API and soon-coming the CLI the that
then hits our control plane which is
running natively in gke and that talks
to other parts of the GCP ecosystem
around authentication for I am for the
for the users that are logging in
pushing metrics into Strack driver
logging metrics for auditing as well as
you know integration into the billing
API and essentially from this
perspective the customer sees a native
volume in their GCP project volumes are
isolated by project and then these
resources are built directly into into
the customers billing account without
having any interaction with net up the
interesting part that is burden that
pertains to VPC peering and such is the
data path setup at the bottom so for
every customer that comes in and every
customer that has a host project
basically we set up a VPC peer
connection between their their VPC and
ours where we provision all of the
resources that are needed to supply all
of the NFS endpoints that they need so
at the bottom of the diagram you see
there's a set of cloud volumes that this
customer has gone ahead and created
these volumes exist on the producer side
so on our side and then we expose mount
points which are RFC 1918 addresses that
they give us back into their
infrastructure so that they can mount
these NFS volumes and essentially access
them from either GCE or gke so what does
private services connectivity do for us
really it's three key things number one
is we really want to simplify the
end-user experience around that data
path setup right so we just want we just
want customers to come in and simply
peer with us and our producer services
to be able to get access we want to
really abstract away all of the
networking complexities that take that
it takes to deliver a service from an
NFS perspective and keep that on our
side and simply exposed the other end of
a VPC peer to the customer with NFS
applications that I meant
like sa P and some of these other
industry specific applications
performance is a very very creaky
criteria most applications need a lot of
throughput and very very low latency and
VPC peering allows us to achieve that
and then finally it gives our customers
a uniform way of accessing services just
like other services like cloud sequel
that Olivia talked about the second big
benefit is private IP it's a private IP
based service for any of you that are
familiar with NFS you realize that the
data that is stored on NFS and the
applications that you use NFS typically
contain sensitive secure data which
means that you can't really have public
endpoints on on an NFS share so this you
know essentially allows customers to
give us their RFC 1918 addresses that
they want to see on these endpoints and
then finally dealing with large
enterprise customers over ninety percent
of them have a shared VPC topology so
being able to support that is a key
requirement for us and again private
services connectivity gives us that as
well so and as Ollivier mentioned so
this allows us to sort of have a
one-time setup from a host project
perspective into our service and then
all of the service projects that follow
I can then just consume these services
without requiring an additional set up
[Music]